What's the Difference Between Green and Black
Tea
Both black and green tea is harvested from
an evergreen, tree-like shrub known as camellia
sinensis.
Most likely originating in China, the camellia
sinensis is thought to have first been used
to brew a medicinal elixir during the Shang
Dynasty (1600 BC to 1046 BC).
By the Qin Dynasty in the third century BC,
it had become a relatively popular drink using
only the leaves from this plant, rather than
mixed with other things as seems to have been
common when used medicinally.
As for the plant itself, camellia sinensis
can grow as tall as 30 ft if left untended,
but is generally kept significantly shorter,
usually only 3-6 ft tall, to make it easier
to harvest the buds and leaves.
It is those that are then processed to become
green or black tea, among other types.
The difference between these teas is achieved
via different processing methods.
Manufacturers create green tea by picking
the leaves off the plant and then heating
them immediately afterwards.
This is commonly done by pan firing the leaves
or steaming them.
Sufficient heat stops the leaves from oxidizing,
allowing them to maintain their green color.
Leaves that are going to be used for black
tea are allowed to ferment, or oxidize, completely.
The general process here is to roll, tear,
or crush the leaves to help along the oxidation
process (similar to why the inside of an apple
turns brown when you expose it to air).
The leaves are then dried out, sometimes in
the Sun or otherwise using machines.
As the leaves oxidize, they gradually turn
from green to black.
Other common types of tea include white and
oolong.
Oolong is initially generally processed in
the same way as black tea, but isn’t allowed
to oxidize for as long.
Once the desired oxidation level has been
reached, which varies quite a bit by type
and manufacturer (some oolong tea is closer
to green tea, while others is closer to black
in oxidation levels), the leaves are fired
similar to green tea to stop the oxidation
process at that point.
White tea is made by picking the leaves and
buds early in the year while the bud is still
closed.
From here, the leaves may be placed out to
dry in the Sun or may be dried out in some
other fashion, in either case attempting to
minimize oxidation during this process.